[Music]
hey Walking Dead fans Liana Galera here
with a familiar face the amazing Michael
Cudlitz aka the latest victim on The
Walking Dead I'm so mad at me again
right now how are you feeling I can't be
mad at me again because it's Jeffrey
Jeffrey's awesome if you gotta be killed
by someone I guess we killed Mike
jeopardy demorgan's all right let Danny
kill me
right just get him a heart for crying
out loud what's going on here the fact
that you're like quoting back to Grey's
Anatomy now aren't you no I'm not
judging you I'm warning you right now
because I was such a huge Abraham fan as
so many of us were talk to me when and
where did you find out that you were
gonna be crushed by Lucille um found out
about a year and four months ago
yes ago yeah that's when Stephen and I
found out initially we knew was coming
I knew that my time in the comic book
had come more was coming so I you know I
was a fan of the show prior so anything
up until that you know if you're a fan
of the show and you see what they've
done in the show you come on the show
you know that your time is limited you
know if there's an expiration date
stamped on the bottom here but so I was
not surprised
I just wanted to want it to be pretty
epic I think that that's it's probably a
common thread that goes through any
actors gonna die on any show you want
your death to be you know epic memorable
but more importantly to honor the life
that the character had and I think
that's what we did you know one of my
concerns going into it was that Stephen
and I were both gonna go on the same
episode in the same time period and I
wanted to make sure that nothing took
away from the death of the Glenn
character it was being a fan of the show
we you know I had a lot vested in in
that character so I wanted to make sure
that that life was celebrated in the
best way possible
and that nothing took away from it so I
think we did a good job think Scott
wrote an amazing script
Greg Nicotero directed an amazing
episode you know and it all goes back to
these characters that Kirkman has
created you know multi-layered just
awesome character is telling great
stories well and the fact that you've
had to keep the secret for a year in
four months is very impressive it's easy
to keep a secret you're not allowed to
say anything about the secrets that are
harder to keep on our show are the
secrets from week to week because we
have things where we'll do press and
they'll tell you you know they have the
screener they've seen it so this is not
gonna air until after it's like okay so
we can talk about the show and what
happens that it and then getting and
then jumping back to know these guys
don't know anything about it so we can
talk about what they've seen so far so
you kind of do a little bit of mental
gymnastics
you know in the middle of all of this
y'all better be putting like me hearts
and unicorns and all kinds of crap drop
one through there and then sad cry basis
it's all good okay it's all good it's
all it's all fine thanks for coming over
your guys are the most awesome fans and
ya know they're ready hearts write
hearts hearts are there better be hearts
anyone leaves now I mean I'm gonna know
I'm gonna go back and watch and see who
and when you left so but no it's fun and
this like honestly this is like the the
interchange and the the relationship we
have with the fans is the best part of
all of it because they they do know us a
little bit outside the show so I think
like when we do something like to talk
and get after the show like last night
and we have a big 90 minute thing in the
whole cast comes everyone gets to see us
and see that we're okay and see that yes
we love Jeffery and you know we're not
you know scarred in some you know
massive way we're not scarred the way
you guys are started sorry about that
you know it's all part of part of the
journey that we all go
we're just grateful for these guys well
talk to me about the prosthetics that it
took to create that skull bashing in
amazingness yeah there's some there's
I'm gonna post later there's some videos
that Steven and I did in the makeup
trailer when we were you have to keep it
like oh we saw Sam yeah they're gonna
they're gonna I have something that that
that didn't air probably cuz they
mentioned product names and stuff but
it's there's some funny ones coming but
Greg Nicotero again who directed this
episode when Greg started on the show he
was basically only the special effects
makeup guy I think he may have been
co-producer on you know early on this is
this is what Greg douses genre this is
what he grew up in horror always wanted
to direct I think that you know this is
the first time he has directed was on
this show I think back in season two or
three and he's when I came on the show
he directed my first episode on my first
scene on and it's interesting just from
from my career being around this so much
I've been very fortunate of the years
seeing a lot of different directors to
see him grow over the years has been
kind of awesome but getting to the point
he's the director but he also runs in
his in charge of the makeup department
still yeah the show so to see his team
come together and and make the pieces
that that made up the different you know
sort of a series of bashing that
happened with Steve and with the eye
covering the eye on having the eye come
out and there was one where it was
further out than the other so it was the
second hit or the third hit it's it's
it's pretty amazing I think that our
makeup crew they're their goal is to
make it so that the the visual effects
team never has to touch anything that
they've done because it looks so good in
because you can't you can't fully
duplicate real you just can't it just
you change in some way you can enhance
real yeah but you can't duplicate it so
they really like to to do the physical
effects as real as possible on site you
know real blood not real blood but real
like liquid where you gather in that
real blood from so yeah it's there's
probably been an hour and a half makeup
hour and a half a makeup we did a test a
couple days prior with the pieces we're
gonna be so that on the day they could
swap out very quickly and go do retakes
so it was it was a big deal you know
basically they put on a ball cap and
they reconstruct everything above what
we're doing in the head you know the
thing is the clip that you showed on
where they showed last night I think had
me with long wig was before everything
had been cut and styled into Abraham's
hair Stephen the same thing we both went
completely bald first then they built it
built up everything from there well I'm
happy to see that you still have
Abraham's mustache maybe still rocking
it they're like it's a little respectful
to the fans that we're gonna go Kenny
we're gonna leave it for a moment so
that nobody feels like I'm in such a
rush to to get rid of this character
it's like a mourning process and y'all
go through well talk to me about filming
that final death scene when you were
going into it were you nervous were you
excited were you a little intimidated I
was honestly the biggest concern for me
going into the whole thing is I you know
I got really crappy knees and I just
read the script and all I read the whole
all I could picture the whole time this
way to enemies I just kept turning pages
and my yeah for excuse me self editing
in my head so nobody got in trouble and
I just kept turning pages and I just
boomer still on her knees and we're
under knees and we're on your knees but
Abraham was like as tall as he's not
possibly not the best choice for comfort
in there but definitely more of a nephew
to neaten yeah yeah but not not not that
was not
Comfort moment oh look it was it was
great because we were we were in a
semi-circle so you you were literally
allowed to not allowed to be here you're
able to look around the room and see
everybody's face and see everybody when
they're doing their work which is kind
of great because we have a we are gifted
with a really really talented cast and
to see everybody do their work for you
know two nights in a row and watch the
reactions and to watch Geoffrey his his
first night coming in he was he was
going between a good wife in our show I
mean we had a very specific slot of time
that we had him for and you know he had
that that tremendous amount of dialogue
to deliver on his first day to a very
well-established cast on the number one
show in the world a show that he is a
fan of to walk in and have everybody
literally on their knees and he's the
guy you know in control and in charge to
watch him build that character of those
two nights was amazing because you know
all the footage the coverage was on the
existing cast already for the first
night and you could see him every take
you know 13 14 takes and throwing stuff
away that didn't work adding stuff back
that did work so that we turned around
the next night and we were back on him
negan was brought to life and you could
see that literally we just had a front
row seat to watching an actor create
literally this character possibly the
most awesome bad guy in television
history not possibly ya know I could say
he could still craft a bed and just
everyone just hates him and no kidding
he's a bad guy he's a very bad guy but
he's fun though
you know he's fun he's fun shut up he's
fun it will be fun it'll be more fun
than you think he's gonna be it's not
gonna be as fun as Denny yeah we're live
right now so they can hear the sound
I'm waiting is what this would sound
guys do now he's mad at me and say he's
gonna he's gonna come over and [ __ ] me
in the head can't some life
[ __ ] me ahead afterwards we're garbage
truck was backing up
we were gonna wait for that but we're
not gonna wait because it's live so we
still better have unicorns and hearts
and the tongues I got emoji well we've
gotta talk about of course your very
last words on walking dead nuts three
amazing words right when you found out
that that was going to be your last and
legacy on The Walking Dead what was your
reaction isn't nothing like a good nut
sucking wait what
all right there no it's fine but no that
was definitely one of the most Abraham
things in a second you're the king of
one-liners on The Walking Dead I will
accept your your dubbing me of that I
will not claim that title although I
happen to agree
what's another one-liner that you've had
on the series that's always been a
personal favorite of yours [ __ ] notes
any one-liners like a one-word or always
with the nuts yeah I always put the nuts
Abraham's got a thing for nuts I guess
he also has a thing for beautiful ladies
yes right we had a lovely Evita and then
also a little remnants brewing with
Sasha yeah when you got to see that
fictional flash-forward where they were
all at the dinner table and we saw
Abraham and Sasha together and happy
what was your thought about that well
Stephen and I could think of was that
that that little baby that was a little
redheaded post-apocalyptic baby do you
think that that is what would have
happened I just think Abraham was
getting busy with everybody with
everybody and there's Eugene just still
DIF loved it every minute of it watchin
watching it oh you won't know what
happened
ask Eugene because he's probably watched
all of it
no that was that was great I think that
literally is one that's a moment of what
could have been you know and then that's
what negan is saying to him and and in
Rick's sort of mind that's the world
that he was trying to create you know
that it that it literally that shot is
what he hoped for all of these people
for his family for his chosen family and
that is a reality that will obviously
never ever you know so I think that's
the audience is sort of like projecting
on that as well that is that is what
they hoped for you know Dukan these
people just find happiness you know can
they just be in a safe place and be
happy and the answer is no because it's
the walking dead and things just don't
end at most hope you have to have a
little bit of hope is that although it's
the most hope well one of the things
that we were talking about that I think
was so fantastic that Chris Hardwick
pointed out was that negan may have
killed Abraham but he didn't beat him
yeah we got a little emotional about it
because I had never really thought of it
that way I thought okay you know he
sacrificed himself Abraham and he gave
himself up but even to the end it was it
really was fu you know it was like I'm
gonna take you out it's like okay your
guys you've cornered us you have you
know logistically in the numbers of it
just don't add up to us being able to
survive this but you know I'm I own this
moment not you you know so it was cool I
hadn't thought of it that way and I'm
glad that it at least some people
perceive it that way well and you
obviously became so close with this
group of people that you filmed with
they really are a family on the show how
does it feel to say goodbye to them how
was hope fun was it last night partying
with them it was great great seeing
everybody cuz I had not been on sat in
in quite a while I've got traveled back
and forth Georgia to sort of keep the
ruse up to keep most most people even if
they thought they knew they were still
enough doubt that they didn't know
you know it's sort of like it's like
having a favorite in a sporting event
like you think they're gonna do the
thing but there's always the possibility
so as long as there's that possibility
and nobody knows for sure then then we
we're still ahead of the game but to
address you know sort of the group that
we have out there we are our family out
there we work in rural Georgia most of
us are working away from home only to
people who actually live there
year-round in the cast and it's it's all
we have out there so you you build on
that and it's a very very giving group a
very you know wonderfully supportive
creatively you know emotionally and
that's who we have out there you know
and so to leave that that that's hard
and just in the sense of saying goodbye
to friends you know picture your sort of
your your your best summer camp ever and
it comes to an end or your your best
sort of you know summer vacation ever
and it comes to an end it's it's
bittersweet you know you say goodbye but
you you you're really excited for what's
next because you don't know what's next
you know and for me I'm gonna place now
where where it's really exciting because
I literally have no idea what's next
because I have not even been able to
pursue work for the last year so there's
literally at the moment like nothing
that might be which is great because it
means everything might be well you know
I actually have something that I'd
really like to pitch right now go ahead
you know there is another show on AMC
that's a prequel I think we're all walk
walked and dead it out you don't want to
just have like some kind of cameo
walking through or if we just feel about
like we need to get I don't think it's
to shows I don't think those two shows
can even exist in the same we're based
on the graphic novel I think which gives
us permission to do things that the
other show doesn't have permission to do
you know they're they're much more bit
there there we base everything we do in
reality so it's believable so we you
know it all has to be based in a reality
so you sort of you know have emotional
impact that shows is much more
based in reality of what would really
happen we have people walking around
looking like this and with crossbows and
you know samurai swords and there's
there's a heightened element to our show
because it's the graphic novel that the
other show doesn't have you know so I
don't think those a lot of our
characters some of them could but I
think a lot of them could transfer into
that world and not look ridiculous I
needed to try
we'll see who knows well lastly for all
those fans out there who are watching
what do you want to say to them
nothing touch the other time with
Twitter ain't nothing to say to you
people will you be able to look at a
baseball bat the same way yeah I'm gonna
go beat the crap out of Jeffrey Dean
Danny gonna beat Denny's ass how about
that let's go beat Denny's ass could
happen I'm fine with that thank you so
much for sitting with us I really
appreciate it and we're honestly gonna
miss you so much on the show
unicorns Hertz trombones ahead of time
bone sure
you